my talk at the table is a cbs morning's
exclusive we are announcing the creation
of the obama chesky scholarship for
public service former president barack
obama and airbnb co-founder and ceo
brian chesky have partnered to give
scholarships to college students
pursuing careers in public service i
love this they announced a 100 million
dollar initiative to recent grads
working in public service who understand
the financial worries of choosing a
public service career
if we could remove that burden
so people can actually go into public
service serve their community
but also broaden the horizons if we want
this next generation of leaders to be
able to do what they need to do
they have to meet each other yeah they
have to know each other they have to
understand each other's communities
they're leaders everywhere we just have
to find them
the voyager scholarship will not only
provide money but also travel stipends
and access to mentors undergraduate
students entering their junior year can
apply at voyager scholarship.obama.org
no later than june 14th vlad you you
mentioned the two of them together
glad you mentioned uh holding on to life
by a thread i think those that work in
public service they are the thread that
holds america together yes so this
scholarship is incorrect and i love that
they're younger we need younger people
because i mean i love experience but if
you're taking a look at the people
running our country they're all in their
70s and 80s
experience is good gail but i i'm with
you i'm with you brian chesky is a great
badass he's young president obama is
also still very right i love it i love
it